hola y bienvenidos a cálculo
multivariable ok y quizás debo decir
antes que nada que soy un gran
entusiasta de las matemáticas y de
verdad que disfruto hacer animaciones
cuando se puede y vaya que es que se
puede cuando se trata de cálculo
multivariable así que quizás la primera
cosa que debemos dejar claro es que
significa esta palabra multivariable
verdad y esto es lo que separa digamos
al cálculo como lo conocemos de este
nuevo tema que estamos por estudiar y
podría decir que todo esto se trata de
funciones multi variables y eso en
realidad no responde nada verdad porque
uno diría bueno que es una función multi
variable y básicamente este tipo de
funciones a los cuales estamos
acostumbrados digamos a trabajar en el
viejo mundo en el en el mundo del
cálculo ordinario simplemente teníamos
una entrada verdad una entrada digamos
equis y nos arrojaba algún tipo de
número como digamos como salida de
verdad digamos
cuadrada muy bien entonces podríamos
llamar a esto una función de una
variable digamos simple verdad
básicamente porque este tipo de aquí es
una sola variable entonces una función
multi variable es algo que maneja muchas
variables así que como sabes digamos es
común escribir esto con xy llevamos a
usar otro color
digamos pensemos en una función f que
depende de dos variables digamos xy pero
por supuesto que que no sólo podrían ser
xy en realidad podríamos poner más
variables digamos x jay-z también
podríamos poner en vez de x jay-z
podríamos poner x 1 x 2 y x 3 y un
montón de cosas pero bueno digamos para
ir iniciando simplemente pensamos en dos
variables y esto nos va a arrojar
digamos una salida verdad que depende de
estos dos entonces típicamente esa
salida será un número pero podríamos
imaginar que este número depende de xy
de jeudi de la siguiente forma podría
ser x cuadrada
y verdad entonces también podríamos
pensar en esta función verdad que tenga
una salida que fuera un vector entonces
podríamos imaginar a esta función efe
que depende de xy de y que nos da un
vector verdad
digamos 3x vamos a poner 3x y 2
ahí lo tenemos entonces esta salida
digamos también es algo que tiene
múltiples variables verdad
digamos 3x eso es una 2 es otra
entonces digo esto no está escrito en
piedra pero las convenciones que
usualmente pensamos a que si tenemos
múltiples números que están en la salida
entonces los los pensamos como si fueran
un vector ok y si hay múltiples números
que están en la entrada simplemente los
escribimos digamos de forma contada como
lo tenemos aquí verdad y los pensamos
como un punto en el espacio a que voy
con esto podríamos pensar en principio
que tenemos una recta numérica y digamos
aquí se encuentra el valor de x verdad y
después podríamos pensar en otra recta
numérica otra recta numérica y digamos
aquí tenemos el valor de de verdad
entonces podríamos pensar de esta forma
y es decir nuestro bar nuestra variable
x y nuestra variable y los pensamos como
dos números
separados verdad como dos entidades
separadas pero quizás sería mucho más
preciso sería mucho más preciso si
consideramos a equis y simplemente
digamos juntos podremos pensarlo en el
plano xy consideramos el plano x y ahora
el xy se corresponde a un punto en este
plano verdad y así pensamos esta función
que toma un punto hacia un número o
quizás hacia un vector y muchas personas
cuando empiezan a enseñar cálculo de
varias variables
simplemente brincan hacia el cálculo y
digo hay muchas muchas cosas que
aprender podríamos hablar de derivadas
parciales gradientes y un montón de
cosas muy divertidas pero lo primero que
yo quiero hacer es digamos pasar un par
de vídeos simplemente hablando de las
distintas formas en que visualizamos los
distintos tipos de funciones multi
variables así que como un vistazo
simplemente vamos a ver algún digamos un
par de ellos rápidamente solo para que
te para que te abra el apetito hacia
todo lo que queremos llegar
pero en los siguientes vídeos si vamos a
entrar en más detalles de todo esto así
que primero las gráficas
cuando hablamos de funciones multi
variables las gráficas se vuelven
tridimensionales pero esto realmente
solo aplica para funciones que tienen
digamos una entrada de dos dimensiones
que podríamos pensar que viven en este
plano xy verdad y un simple número
digamos va a hacer su salida y así la
altura de esta gráfica va a corresponder
con la de dicha salida y como dije serás
capaz de aprender mucho más acerca de
esto en el vídeo dedicado a este tema
pero estas funciones también pueden ser
visualizadas en dos dimensiones digamos
aplanando todo esto donde visualizamos
todo el espacio de entradas completo con
un color asociado en cada punto y este
es el tipo de cosas en donde tienes una
función digamos con entradas de dos
dimensiones digamos efe de x
y digamos que esto nos da una salida que
es un número digamos x cuadrada ok y
sabemos que a lo mejor podemos tener
otras cosas más complicadas verdad y el
color nos dice digamos el tamaño de la
salida y las líneas de aquí se le llama
curvas de nivel
qué nos dice digamos todos las todas las
entradas que comparten una salida en
común verdad un mismo valor de salida y
otra vez vamos a entrar en más detalle
de esto y esto en realidad es muy bonito
mucho más conveniente que las gráficas
tridimensionales para ir haciendo
algunos esbozos también vamos a hablar
de superficies en tres dimensiones
verdad que parecen como gráficas pues en
realidad estamos hablando de un animal
mucho más más raro verdad que podríamos
pensar como un mapeo de dos dimensiones
verdad y de alguna forma tenemos una
entrada de dos dimensiones y se mueve en
tres dimensiones que es lo que estamos
viendo aquí verdad la salida es
justamente como estando una verdad y en
realidad no nos está importando cómo es
que llega ahí a estas se les llama
superficies parametrizados otro tema
divertido es el de los campos
vectoriales en donde cada punto de
entrada se le asocia a un vector verdad
porque es la salida de nuestra función
así que sería una función con una
entrada en dos dimensiones y una salida
en dos dimensiones la de la parte
divertida con estos tipos es que puedes
digamos imaginar un
un fluído que está justamente fluyendo y
puedes pensar en un montón de gotitas
como si fuera agua verdad que están
fluyendo a través de este plano verdad y
eso de hecho nos da cierta idea de cuál
es la función que hay detrás verdad es
uno de esos aspectos muy bellos del
cálculo multi variable y vamos a tener
mucha exposición de este tema
otra vez simplemente estamos tratando de
digamos abrir tu apetito para este tema
no importa si esto no tiene mucho
sentido inmediatamente para ti y
finalmente mi forma favorita de pensar a
las funciones multivariable se es
justamente tomar el espacio de entradas
que en este caso va a ser una función
que tiene puntos como entradas en un
espacio de dos dimensiones y podemos ver
cómo es que se mueven hacia sus salidas
así que esto va a ser una función que
también tiene salida en dos dimensiones
y vamos a ver como cada punto verdad se
va a mover hacia donde se supone que
tiene que ir y quizás esto puede ser
complicado de ver al inicio verdad o al
menos de pensarlo pero a medida que
ganemos un poquito de intuición y cierta
exposición al tema verás que es muy
bonito y qué
digamos una muy bella conexión con el
álgebra lineal y quizás muchos de
ustedes ya es que estén ahorita
estudiando cálculo multivariable quizás
están por estudiar álgebra lineal o ya
lo están estudiando en este momento pero
bueno al fin al final de cuentas las
funciones digamos las podemos ver como
transformaciones y eso será una forma
muy muy buena para conectar estos dos
temas así que con esto voy a voy a
pararle a la plática en este vídeo así
que en los siguientes vídeos vamos a
entrar con más detalle en todos estos
temas y espero que tengan una muy buena
sensación de que son las funciones
multivariable y cómo es que se siente
trabajar con ellas